fingers crossed Iijima temple pray to
the monks that this thing does not stick
right when in Lao take advantage of the
local ingredients and do a refreshing
delicious omelette if it starts to stick
to the side of the wall then I'll turn
into scrambled eggs first endo got my
aromatics in there the most amazing
shallots garlic chili a little bit of
palm sugar the most amazing herbs basil
fresh mint dill do now this literally
create a really nice paste in to the
hubs
don't touch a fish sauce that will give
it a little bit of acidic and seasoning
from there pounding the ingredients yeah
what do you think of Lao cuisine is
about the sourness bitterness power the
chilies get that down to a nice pulp
made out of the rice now from there
crack the eggs go straight in there it
may look like a different way of making
an amazing omelette or scrambled eggs
but trust me it's gonna make sense in a
minute mix that up now no seasoning okay
because of depending on that fragrance
from the herbs the chili is also on that
essence of Lao inside on there
right my walk is getting nice and hot
now if this is a proper nonstick walk
then I'll make a beautiful omelette with
fresh herbs in the middle let's see what
we're up against see that literally
cooking within seconds
like any omelette needs to be a little
bit running in the middle but push that
against the side that looks beautiful
and then from there as it starts to cook
let's open that up
get my herbs and just break some fresh
herbs into the center of my omelette I'd
be useful delicious amazing on their
touch of seasoning in the center and
then let's cross heat to my temple pray
to the monks that this thing does not
stick here we go tap-tap
Iblees is delicious now trust me that
may look slightly different do you know
homeless
delicious eating with the Flies
trust me another source of protein let
me know in the comments what you think
of that amazing scrambled egg dish and
if you missed uncharted trust me you can
watch it on the link below or on the
NatGeo app